bien que le monde sait ce qu aux
étudiants se retrouvent sur vos [ __ ]
de coup de tonnerre sur sneijder mention
une nouvelle version de sender écouter
cette fois on ne doit pas la basse et
des pages on doit pas passer des espèces
de nounours en peluche je sais pas
pourquoi on doit ramasser des objets
[ __ ] c'est glauque au iliad est pareil
à l'espèce de titres et qui me stressait
dans les montagnes marolles et ce sont
les puissances mais il sait après cela
on doit ramasser en fait des objets je
ne sais pas quoi ça jo pas d'or
bon il est déjà essoufflé
bon ok c'est l'histoire d'un mec dans un
manoir immense on ne sait pas pourquoi
il est là il veut trouver des objets ça
se trouve il ya des trucs immense
apprendre plus jeune âge bon enfin tu
sais que cette forme au croyable oh
[ __ ] way un téléphone hockey au [ __ ]
ça il ya le bruit ok on a déjà trouvé un
truc pas mal nagé trouve un truc aller
au 2o mon dieu est cette fois on va le
voir on va l'avoir
je vous jure comment l'avoir donc tu
regardes la toilette toutes les femmes
peuvent être des trucs de fou par
exemple il ya du rin c'est un truc de
fou ça va attendez je suis sûr que les
honnêtes mans il ya moyen combattre là
dedans y'a pas un truc là dedans non sur
lui non plus bon continue en termes plus
c'est super c'est à dire que si tu
tombes sur sneijder tu te fais caca
dessus comédiens une toile
au piano ah non ça fait plutôt peur
peut-être pour l'élan cool non plus voir
plus j'ai l'impression de voir l'espèce
de tretiak ans länder arrive à l'égout
tonnerre ça c'est quoi c'est la grande
piste il n'y a pas un truc à prendre
dans la grimpée du début n'ont pas de
téléphone la bouteille la bouteille
[ __ ] j'ai eu peur la bouteille pour se
défendre moi je dis non au vaillant
panetta je peux aller tâche c'est parti
laitages bon c'est parti alors je vous
parie que non je vous parie y tue la
porte est fermée voilà c'était sûr et
certain mais tout ça
il est là au [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] j'ai eu un petit bleu en fait
j'ai cru cet intrus du décor sa main de
sa main tout flasque cela dégueulasse la
voudraient-ils allègrement leur
plastique manches même tu mais d'autres
dont ils tous suivent dedans pour pour
rigoler en quarts noir un carambar
[ __ ] c'est goût fraise je sais plus
quoi c'est trop long mon dieu
[ __ ] elle m'a fait peur le salon oh
oui moi c'est magnifique c'est
magnifique au téléphone un autre
téléphone
non non une radio du vin une boîte
jusqu'ici plénitude du monde
un tableau un tableau très utile dans
mon élément plus mon dieu elle allait en
continu continu aux petits leur poule je
suis sûr franchement on est trop malin
non j'aime pas la petite série là mais
bon il ya le karma c'est pratique pour
trouver son chemin par contre lui 40
marques
j'adore cette idée du combat honnêtement
génial mais par contre ce qu'ils mangent
génial ces casses länder qui va pas fort
les olympus s'énerve qui va paraître un
moment à l'autre
talât aux dix mois que c'est la clé
d'ici dis moi oui non phoque vitraux mon
âge est trompeur car 0 tu te sac c'est
bon il est pas là ils parlaient pas là
il va pas être là bas non épaissi fonds
mais aussi font le piano tam jugé aucun
en fait je serais tellement que j'ai eu
aucun sens d'orientation sais je vais
n'importe où en priant but important en
priant pour tomber sur un truc là on est
déjà venu par la [ __ ] j'ai omis une
galette c'est qu'on s'est touché mon
dieu pour être posé un post-it ce serait
aberrant un post-it super la balle à
balai entre qui entrera sur tout le
temps de voir s'il est là en plus notre
pourquoi il eu ça ça veut dire qu'il a
un côté normand connaître sa salle au
sable aux salles au salon j'te j'te fuck
un truc
c'est reparti écouter la chute
déterminée pour défoncer sa petite tête
toute blanche d'entraîneur était toute
blanche un espèce d'ailleurs dans les
mannequins et c'est là même ses
mannequins dans le magasin avec les
vêtements et ben c'est exactement la
même scène dans la même gueule enfin
bref c'est parti c'est à dire là pas de
gueule alors encore hamas s'est tous mis
assez génial on continue alors là
falloir ramasser des objets dans celui
là honnêtement c'est pas parce que j'ai
tenté de le faire avant que je sais où
sur les objets sachant que c'est
impossible de s'y retrouver et voir
là-haut up téléphone voilà c'est presque
les seuls à peu pris chez où ils sont le
rsa va être feeling lâché qu'il faut une
clé pour aller en bas valais on va aller
aux nouvelles pièces on va aller dans
celle-ci déjà obligé une boîte c'est
super aussi une boîte et d'armoires
abass ndao ça fait pas le prendre
on dirait un carambar c'est les
carambars la jaune et violet ou trop
beau en plus trop trop trop non j'ai
fais quoi ses framboises cassis via six
quelque chose on voit le pro carol bartz
est
on en poule la blague énorme il faut
vraiment cliqué sur tous tués à au
tableau messieurs je vais trail du clip
le piano non mais c'est l'orage se fait
peur est là honnêtement les gens je suis
auger une christine clay west inc les
choix là je suis vraiment chaud
bouillant pour compte des fonds sneijder
a honnêtement des coups de matraques ont
valu m oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] la toile
au nom non pas le piano pas le piano mon
dieu c'est horrible je déteste ça reste
dans sa on en vient on en vient de là on
en vient on pas dit s'il me semble qu'on
en vient à aa
les concours corps derrière samedi à
blizzard qui traînent dans la maison
tranquillement qui veut peut-être ta
peau aussi oppressant allait obliger oui
une savonnette internet oui
[ __ ] de sa mère sait pas où aller mais
on est déjà venu ici tu peux honnêtement
si on ne peut pas ouvrir la porte qui
est en bas on est mort oui oui oh oui
cette chance jamais jamais réussir une
passe jamais comme la caméra n'a plus
beaucoup de batterie je suis belge
allait à l'année passée à huy ça ça se
prend non ça ça brille en position
foetale position foetale position
foetale plus sur cet album est en
position foetale
on va essayer de longer les murs n'ont
cessé de baisser le rideau
blu ray et sa flore et sa cour